nous répondrons à toutes frappes
aériennes israéliennes de manière
appropriée et proportionnée pour
protéger notre pays
hassan nasrallah a averti l'état hébreu
ce dimanche dans une allocution
télévisée
en face naftali bennet met en garde le
gouvernement et l'armée libanaise contre
les conséquences du comportement de m
aulas des déclarations qui interviennent
quelques jours après des tirs de
roquettes et d'artillerie entre les deux
camps
le pass sanitaire assoupli à la veille
de son enfant
coeur peut être suite à la forte
mobilisation d'hier partout en france
qui a réuni selon les autorités deux
cent trente sept mille personnes
le dépistage négative sera désormais
valable 72 heures pour les non vaccinés
et non plus 48 heures comme c'était le
cas jusqu'ici
il sera aussi possible d'effectuer des
tu est supervisé par un professionnel de
santé
[Musique]
et
bonsoir bienvenue si vous nous retrouver
sur rt france et talibans gagnent du
terrain en afghanistan avec sa ré poule
koundouz des taloqan à les rebelles se
sont emparés ce dimanche de trois
nouvelles capitales provinciales
exécutif et l'armée afghanes semble dans
l'incapacité d'enrayer l'offensive des
talibans lancée en mai au début du
processus de désengagement des troupes
américaines aient les détails avec
françois this kiewit chez clément
hospital ils sont des dizaines à être
arrivés ces derniers jours dont cette
petite ville de la province de kunar des
familles contraintes de fuir les combats
entre talibans et forces de sécurité
afghanes
[Musique]
nous avions une bonne vie dans notre
village nous avions tous mais à cause
des combats entre les forces de sécurité
et les talibans tout a été détruit
comme vous le voyez toutes ces familles
se sont juste sauvé les talibans ont
tout pillé les talibans ont attaqué puis
nous avons quitté notre village nous
sommes juste vais sans aucun bien ni
vêtements maintenant nous sommes venus
ici et nous vivons dans cet écueil sur
le terrain des combats les talibans se
sont emparés en deux jours de quatre
capitales provinciales des offensives
révélatrice de la stratégie des insurgés
de s'attaquer désormais aux centres
urbains après avoir d'abord porté leurs
attaques sur les campagnes et les
pourtours frontaliers même à kaboul les
talibans sévices avec l'assassinât
vendredi du chef du service de
communication du gouvernement et dans
les rues de la capitale
l'inquiétude des habitants grandi
si vous demandez à la plupart des
afghans 99% d'entre vous diront que les
combats ne résoudront pas les crises
actuelles
la seule solution c'est la paix et c'est
ce que veut le peuple afghan dans les
deux cas les personnes tuées sont des
afghans et sont originaires de ce pays
selon la commission afghane indépendante
des droits humains près d'un million de
personnes ont été déplacées au cours des
trois derniers mois soit depuis la date
du début du retrait définitif des forces
étrangères du pays une situation suivie
de près par l'organisation des nations
unies qui prévient que la guerre en
afghanistan est entrée dans une nouvelle
passe plus meurtrière des forces de
sécurité afghanes sont aujourd'hui dans
l'incapacité de lutte de lutter avec les
talibans en raison de la corruption
c'est en tout cas ce que pense françois
chauvancy il est général de brigade et
expert en géostratégie
on dit que l'armée afghane effectivement
on n'a pas tous les moyens
rappelons quand même que les états unis
ont dépensé depuis vingt ans en
afghanistan
près de 2000 milliards de dollars soit
en gros 1700 milliards d'euros c'est
énorme de l'équipement a été donné des
formations ont été donnés des cadres ont
été formés dans les armes étrange dans
les pays étrangers alors effectivement
on peut s'étonner de ce manque
d'équipement avérée moi j'aurai le
sentiment que la corruption qui règne
dans ce pays a largement au béret et
capacités militaires de la mer bonne
d'une part et peut-être aussi que
l'armée afghane n'est pas en mesure
aujourd'hui idéologiquement de se battre
contre les talibans est la limite je
pourrais presque avoir le sentiment
qu'elle est déjà travailler de
l'intérieur pour laisser tomber
finalement le gouvernement qui est en
place aujourd'hui
poussée de fièvre à la frontière
libano-israélienne le hezbollah et
l'armée israélienne ont en effet changé
les tirs d'artillerie et des roquettes
ces derniers jours mais la tension
semblait être redescendue
hier les deux camps affirment malgré
tout être prêt à répliquer en cas de
nouvelles offensives adverses
yamina benguigui et la trame est ce une
réponse appropriée et proportionnée
ce sont les mots du secrétaire général
du hezbollah
une promesse faite samedi et visant
israël
dans le cas où son armée pour suivre et
les bombardements aériens
l'organisation chiite et l'état hébreu
échangent des tirs à la frontière libano
israélienne depuis au moins trois jours
un high rider oui c'est là tout
bombardement aérien de l'aviation
israélienne sur le liban sera
inévitablement suivie d'une réponse mais
d'une manière appropriée et
proportionnée
car nous souhaitons protéger notre pays
nous ne cherchons pas la guerre et nous
ne voulons pas nous diriger vers une
guerre mais nous y sommes préparés et
nous n'avons pas peur nous attendons la
victoire chaque jour et nous
l'obtiendrons avec la volonté de dieu
voit sa note à sanofi des bombardements
aériens sur le liban après le tirs non
revendiqués de trois roquettes depuis le
pays du cèdre suivi d'une réplique du
hezbollah qui a lancé une vingtaine de
roquettes vers l'état hébreu qui a
répondu par des tirs d'artillerie
la loi du talion prends tu ici son sens
systématique les deux camps disent
rejeté une escalade du conflit mais se
disent prêts à se défendre contre une
nouvelle attaque
bagheera les vallons les pièges y
toreros trash obama sur le front
libanais on assiste à un réveil très
important de nombreuses personnes dont
le pays contre le hezbollah rhj et
l'implication iranienne dans le pays
au milieu d'une grave crise politique
l'iran et le hezbollah compliquer la
situation du peuple libanais y compris
sur le front israélien le pays l'armée
libanaise doivent assumer la
responsabilité de ce qui se passe dans
leur arrière-cour
ici aussi nous importe moins que ce soit
une organisation palestinienne est tirée
ou sur des rebelles indépendant et c'est
israël n'acceptera pas que l'on tire sur
ses terres le chitra les civils piégés
par ces affrontements s'inquiètent de
voir le conflit prendre de l'ampleur ils
craignent la répétition d'anciens
combats meurtriers
la situation est tendue nous avons vécu
une période similaire dans les années 70
lorsque les combattants palestiniens
mener des attaques de guérilla contre
israël
nous en sommes maintenant même point et
cela provoque des tensions pour l'onu le
conflit y est dangereux et doit cesser
immédiatement
nous sommes préoccupés par l'escaladé de
la violence notamment les tirs de
roquettes vers israël ainsi que les
frappes aériennes et les tirs
d'artillerie en réponse de l'autre côté
de la ligne bleue ces derniers jours
nous appelons toutes les parties à faire
preuve de la plus grande retenue et à
préserver la stabilité
le liban ne peut pas se permettre une
crise supplémentaire des tensions
régionales qui coïncide avec le conflit
opposant israël à l'iran après la taxe
d'un pétrolier géré par un milliardaire
israélien en mer domaine l'état hébreu
pointe téhéran qui nie toute
responsabilité
la république islamique d'iran soutien
historique du hezbollah les tirs
d'artillerie eux sont effectués depuis
le plateau du golan territoire syrien
occupé par israël depuis 1967
ce conflit met en scène trois
protagonistes différents dossiers
sensibles et des tensions qui se
multiplient
israël ou des mesures restrictives
supplémentaires entre en vigueur ce
dimanche pour faire face à la
propagation du colis de 19
la vignette verte est de retour il faut
donc de nouveau présenté ce document ou
un test négatif pour toute une série
d'activités dans les restaurants bars ou
encore salles de sport retour également
du masque à l'extérieur pour les
rassemblements les plus de 100 personnes
est les autorités lancent par ailleurs
un programme de tests rapides programme
qui a débuté à jérusalem israël qui est
le pays le plus vacciner au monde fait
face un malgré cela à une flambée
épidémique le variant indiens aussi
appelée delta donne du fil à retordre un
peu partout dans le monde en iran 24
heures il a causé la mort de plus de 500
personnes et en a contaminé près de
quarante mille autres à triste record
depuis le début de la pandémie la
république islamique est considérée
comme le pays le plus touché par le kobe
19 au proche et moyen-orient est les
autorités comptent sur la vaccination
pour freiner la pandémie est mais le
rythme vaccinale peine à s'accélérer
seuls 3,7 millions de personnes ont reçu
les deux injections nécessaires selon le
ministère de la santé
sur les 83 millions d'habitants et les
variants delta n'est pas le seul à
susciter l'inquiétude plusieurs
mutations ont fait leur apparition
depuis le début de la pandémie
la dernière en date la b 1 621 surnommé
variant colombien plutôt discret jusqu'à
présent il se retrouve au coeur de
l'attention et pour cause il a causé la
mort de 7 personnes vaccinées en
belgique monnaie hamou dès lors après le
variant onglet sud africain et le delta
indien voici un nouvel arrivant le
variant colombien il a déjà frappé et
fait sept morts parmi elles et 20 cas
positifs détectés dans un ehpad belge
résidents et personnel tous été vaccinés
à l'exception d'un étudiant l
établissement indique ne pas savoir
comment le virus s'est incrusté faut-il
s'en inquiéter
selon l' oms c'est en colombie au mois
de janvier 2
21 qu'il est identifié pour la première
fois trente pays ont relevé sa présence
n'est en minorité en france seulement
neuf cas ont été repérés mais les
variants nous ont réservé bien des
surprises ces derniers mois et tout peut
aller très vite
même si ce variant reste marginal nous
savons que ce nouveau variant est en
belgique depuis la fin du mois de juin
mais en très faible pourcentage
une enquête menée en angleterre a montré
que ce variant n'est pas plus pathogène
que ceux que nous connaissons déjà mais
il est encore trop tôt pour faire des
déclarations définitives pour l'instant
sur le sol français 93% des cas de
contamination sont ovarian delta selon
santé publique france d'après les
autorités sanitaires britanniques
rien ne permet de conclure qu'il
devancera à l'avenir le variant delta
peu de données existent mais ils ne
seraient pas plus transmissible ou
contagieuse qu'un d'autres variant marc
van ranst appelle néanmoins à la
vigilance
on ne sait pas comment le virus va se
propager nous devons suivre la situation
il est certain qu'il va se propager mais
le variant delta est tellement puissant
qu'il est improbable mais pas impossible
que ça continue d'augmenter
autre question est il plus résistants
aux vaccins à ce stade les données sont
encore faibles mais les autorités
sanitaires britanniques estiment qu'il
serait proche du variant bêta identifiés
en afrique du sud
pour rappel l'étude comme corps de
l'institut pasteur révèle qu'un schéma
vaccinal complet avec les vaccins arn
messagers de files heures bio and take
our ou modern à protéger à 77% d'une
contamination aux variants bêta selon
rémi salomon le président de la
commission médicale de l'ap-hp il
pourrait être plus résistants à
l'humidité vaccinale mais moins
transmissibles pourquoi et comment le
virus mute il les virus muté il évolue
lorsqu ils infectent les cellules d'un
hôtel réplique
c'est cette transformation du code
génétique qui l'aide à passer d'un
humain à l'autre la survie du virus
dépend donc de ces mutations car elles
vont permettre aux microbes de s'adapter
aux différents hôtes qu'il infecte et
donc de grandir sous différentes
manières et de prospérer reste à savoir
comment le variant colombien évoluera il
s'est en tout cas l'objet d'une
surveillance renforcée de là
part de l'om est-ce alors affaire à
suivre j - 20 avant l'entrée en vigueur
de l'extension du passani terre en
france il sera demandé à l'entrée des
restaurants bars cafés mais aussi dans
les transports de longue distance comme
l'avion certains trains et cars à des
assouplissements à son application
viennent d'être apportées
les tests de dépistage seront désormais
valable de 72 72 heures et non et 48
heures comme c'était le cas jusqu'à
présent
autre nouveauté il sera aussi possible
d'effectuer des autotests à condition
qu'ils soient supervisées par des
soignants annonce ce matin d'olivier
vers ans chez nos confrères du parisien
le ministre a de la santé qui s'est par
ailleurs félicitée du rythme de la
vaccination en france
nous réalisons actuellement entre 300 et
400 milles primo injection par jour et
nous sommes déjà à plus de 44 millions
nous attendons un creux au coeur du mois
d'août
mais l'objectif de 50 millions de primo
injection fait à la fin du mois soit
plus de 85% des 58 millions de français
vaccinable devrait être atteint un pass
and et arqués continue d'être dénoncé à
travers la france irl et à plus de deux
cent trente sept mille manifestants dans
les rues d'après les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur
480 mille d'après le syndicat france
police policiers en colère il dénonçant
ces manifestants une loi sanitaire qui
ne respectent pas les libertés
individuelles
une mobilisation en hausse pour son 4e
samedis consécutifs
retour sur cette journée de
manifestation avec walid ben ali une
figure des gilets jaunes transformer
presque en chef d'orchestre des chants
et de la musique pour se réchauffer en
plein mois d'août
des dizaines de milliers de parisiens
présents dans les plus grandes artères
de la ville une manifestation par qui
est également de neuilly sur seine avec
plusieurs ponts carte très évocatrice
[Musique]
bah moi j'ai un pour manifester pour ma
liberté faire du sport tout simplement
on va m'interdire faire du sport pour
moi c'est ma vie c'est essentiel donc
j'ai un juste pour ma liberté moi je
suis très solidaire avec tous les gens
qui sont dans l'obligation vaccinale
parce que c'est c'est un peu du chantage
qu'on eut refait
c'est vraiment forcer la main aux gens
sur des questions qui sont vraiment très
très intime parce que ça touche à notre
corps ça touche médical etc
une quatrième semaine consécutive à
défiler en plus grand nombre et sous
haute protection des forces de l'ordre
bien en place devant et sur les côtés du
cortège
[Musique]
le mot protection qui fait aujourd'hui
débat une protection notamment
sanitaires et encadré qui ne passe pas
du côté de certains politiques mobilisés
samedi
pourquoi est ce que les professions
comme les forces de nantes qui sont
exemple et donc quand les sapeurs
pompiers qui ne le sont pas on ne peut
pas accepter de montrer son état
sérologique son carnet vaccinal pour
aller prendre un café en terrasse pour
prendre un train
cependant le droit de travailler enfin
on est ou dont la capitale mais
également dans l'aube
les troyens réunis en nombre devant leur
préfecture leur mairie et dans le centre
ville
on veut le droit de pouvoir choisir si
on veut nourrir du président ou pas
contre le pain sanitaires ou et contre
une vaccination obligatoire les
sentiments sont partagés dans le sud-est
de la france ils étaient plus de 47000 a
protesté à marseille avec en première
ligne certains personnels soignants
syndiqués a lyon quelques échauffourées
et sept interpellations sont à noter
samedi soir les autorités ont dénombré
181 18 actions en france des
revendications important également dans
les départements d'outre-mer les
guadeloupéens ont fait entendre leur
voix
toute la journée et ce malgré une
interdiction de sortir à dix kilomètres
de chez soi
karim khelfaoui médecin généraliste à
marseille comprend la méfiance envers le
gouvernement
mais estime que la vaccination reste la
meilleure arme pour lutter contre le coc
u19 ils ont des raisons d'avoir des
méfiances en particulier quand on a un
pouvoir comme ça qui est complètement
discrédité n'a pas arrêté mentir mais il
ne donne pas à confondre le geste de
travail on jette enfin et là est ce
qu'il en est pour le mandant contre la
colite 19 ce n'est pas le miracle que le
gouvernement est en train de décrire
parce qu'un jour ou l'autre on va se
rendre compte que ça va pas suffire
indiqué la situation aussi sa limite
énormément les choses en particulier en
termes de formes de bas baker un terrain
de comptage le site etc
alors on voit qu'ils commencent à sortir
on voit que le variant d'état par
exemple dans les premiers jours de
réflexion d'une personne vaccinée mais
on peut être très contagieuse aussi là
contrairement à ce que raconte le père
demain donc il faut faire attention
c'est la meilleure a répondu aujourd'hui
il faut ne pas hésiter à l'utiliser
parce qu'elle est sûre elle efficace
maintenant clairement contraindre les
personnes sans assumer la responsabilité
juridique ça ne marchera pas
les jeux de tokyo sont terminés tous les
regards sont désormais tournés vers
paris la capitale française organisera
en effet les prochaines olympiades en
avant les athlètes français de retour
dans l'hexagone ont tenu à célébrer
leurs médailles devant la tour eiffel 33
au total la maire de paris étaient de la
partie on lui a confié le drapeau
olympique
anne hidalgo qui affirme organiser ces
jeux dans le respect de l'environnement
les précisions damas y assembler des
jeux olympiques inédit entachée par la
pandémie
mais à paris malgré tout réussi pour le
comité international olympique qui passe
désormais la main à paris en 2024
un grand défi attend la capitale
française notamment en terme d'écologie
paris se rêve en symbole d'une nouvelle
ère pour les jeux olympiques qui
laissera un héritage durable au pays
ces jeux vont nous faire du bien le
combat écologique est aussi au coeur de
la transformation de notre ville est au
coeur de la proposition que nous avons
fait et d'ailleurs de marseille à tahiti
en passant par la seine et la seine
saint denis
au coeur de ces jeux il y aura ces
transformations écologiques mais aussi
les transformation de nos modes de vie
et c'est d'ailleurs cette perspective
qui nous a guidés aussi en ce qui
concerne les jeux et leur héritage des
lieux emblématiques de la capitale
seront investis tels que la place de la
concorde
le grand palais la tour eiffel objectif
ne pas répéter les mêmes erreurs du
passé
comme mario cinq ans après loin de
l'ambiance festive des jeux olympiques
brésilien les infrastructures sont à
l'abandon et la nature a repris ses
droits
un cadre sinistre qui désole les
habitants j'ai vu cet endroit quand ils
ont ouvert c'était bien totalement
organisé propre et avec le temps nous
avons vu des choses incohérentes dans le
lieu des zones fermées à la vue du
public avec des matériaux de
construction abandonné par la mairie une
honte
avec le temps la végétation a pris le
dessus sur l'arrière la partie initiale
la partie avant est bien entretenu mais
concernant l'arrière
il ne s'en occupe pas donc c'est
vraiment dommage tant que d'un droit
d'auteur
certains projets qui devait naître après
les jeux ont été abandonnées comme le
parc olympique qui devait devenir un
site d'entraînement géré par le ministre
brésilien des sports la ville de rio
avait promis des équipements durables
dans le temps un engagement non tenu qui
a de lourdes conséquences
environnementales et financières
la facture finale des jeux olympiques de
rio s'élève à plus de 11 milliards
d'euros
frédéric dia les membres du collectif
non aux jeux olympiques de 2024
il explique pourquoi selon lui
l'organisation des jeux de 1024 par
paris serait un désastre réalité en
terme d'emploi et en termes de
croissance et jeux olympiques ou finale
entre les dépenses budgétaires et ce
qu'ils retombent
on est proche de zéro en réalité est
donc là dessus il ya beaucoup de
communication notamment de la part de
anne hidalgo qui racontent beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses là-dessus et
beaucoup de choses totalement
approximative est fausse mais en termes
de croissance et c'est quasi nul
en revanche ce qui est certain c'est que
en termes budgétaires c'est une
catastrophe en termes écologiques c'est
une catastrophe
direction les états-unis ou dixie fire
continue sa course folle le gigantesque
incendie ravage actuellement l'ouest
américain cinq personnes sont toujours
portées disparues en californie est les
flammes ont déjà dévoré plus de 180
mille hectares dans quatre comtés depuis
que le feu s'est déclaré à la mi juillet
alors vous le voyez sur ces images le
gouverneur de californie s'est déplacé
en personne pour constater l'ampleur des
dégâts
5000 pompiers s'activent sur le terrain
pour contenir les flammes situation tout
aussi alarmante en grèce en proie à des
incendies meurtriers depuis douze jours
alors si athènes semble désormais
protégé le feu étant maîtrisé autour de
la capitale
ce n'est pas le cas de l'île d'eubée qui
est dévasté par les flammes
c'est une grande partie de l'europe du
sud 1 qui y est confronté à de virulents
incendies et des températures
caniculaires
après avoir pleuré ses morts la turquie
elle bénéficie ce dimanche d'une pluies
providentielles cyrielle beau et les
incendies font toujours rage en grèce
depuis plus de dix jours des feux
violent ravagent le pays
les vents forts ainsi que les
températures élevées rendent la maîtrise
des incendies particulièrement difficile
face à cette tragédie
la priorité du gouvernement est claire
protéger au maximum les habitants
nous devons poursuivre avec une grande
intensité l'effort pour limiter tous les
incendies et ne pas avoir de risque de
rallumage la priorité de tous ces
derniers jours a été avant tout la
protection de la vie humaine dans la
mesure du possible de protéger les
propriétés notamment pour que le feu ne
pénètre pas dans les habitations
car dans ce cas nous aurions de gros
dégâts et bien sûr la protection des
infrastructures critiques qu'avaient ils
peuvent pas fait pour une collection des
incendies qui progresse dangereusement
vers la capitale hellénique athènes
d'énormes nuages de fumées et de cendres
ont obligé les habitants de la région à
quitter leur domicile
de retour chez eux il constate les
dégâts nous avions déjà une idée en
regardant en direct à la télévision et
en voyant tout en feu nous sommes partis
le coeur lourd
maintenant nous sommes de retour et
c'est pire nous espérons que tout ira
bien
la destruction est importante les
maisons ont été brûlées mais
heureusement il n'ya pas eu de victime
cependant la destructions des propriétés
de l'habitat naturel et massive
c'est un terrible désastre
d'après ce que je vois le feu atteint le
lac marathon j'ai peur que nos arrières
petits enfants ne puissent plus se
promener ici c'est une tragédie
inimaginable
plus de cent cinquante incendies ont été
signalés sur le territoire grec pour
faire face à la situation plusieurs pays
européens dont la france ont envoyé des
renforts des conditions météorologiques
extrêmes qui témoigne de la réalité du
changement climatique selon les experts
même constat en turquie pays voisin où
13e reste actif mais où la situation
semble se stabiliser grâce à la chute de
pluies dans le sud-ouest du pays
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité ce sera dans une trentaine
de minutes reste
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer cinq ans de psychodrame
50 négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe ou pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'un compte